hello
and welcome to another night of chess on
psychology aka
topalov games yeah my obsession with
topalov's games is still continues
i don't know how long this will continue
but man
he has some really nice games um
i think that might also be a little
influenced by
me becoming good friends with a new
bulgarian girl
my newest teammates um gabriella
so i guess that's also another
thing to consider about all right so
enough about my
obsession with bulgars uh let's
let's talk some chess so i wanted to
initially talk a little instead of to
polyp to talk about
the accordance norway tournament but
honestly i feel like
everybody is talking about it so i kind
of like to take a step back and
just look at some older games some a
little bit
more i would say classic games
or um same with like us just
championship games
either the juniors women junior girls
or junior boys i feel like that's
something that's
still going on and they have such a
strong commentary so i'm gonna
i'm gonna go ahead and look at some
other games so this specifically
was a game that was oh god
oh my god i probably need to address the
board i apologize
a little issue here my bad
hold on hold on working on it shouldn't
be too horrible
just made the small mistake of
thinking i was gonna do something and
then i realized that wasn't
i apologize for the adjustments
okay
okay i'm good at this cropping huh
probably should be a little bit more oh
that's a little more than a little bit
oh my goodness okay
sorry about that i've i have like a
split screen
and i didn't realize until the last
minute that
i needed to fix that okay um
where is my camera why would my camera
be here i'm
i'm kind of streaming from home so
that's a very funny question
okay yeah it's good now yeah uh thank
you for
um waiting on me and while i fix that
small issue it
shouldn't have happened sorry um okay
let's just make sure it's not showing me
any other thing
i might be showing i got a suggestion
last time
i was streaming that when i tried to
like
look at the the bar that i actually have
no idea how to
not have the bar there some players
could take a
peek at it and it could affect their
evaluation of the
position so yeah i'm kind of um
trying not to show that okay i think
every technical thing is good though
yeah all right so uh this game was a
very interesting game
between topolof and kramek so there are
a lot of interesting game between the
polyp and crown nick but chess wise i
think this one
probably is my favorite um at least
from just i feel like this is just
it was just so awesome and um
the cat was fit the cat wants to go out
even though he was out for like an hour
and a half
the cat always wants to go out can't
really do anything about that
unless there aren't any volunteers to
come walk my cat
i don't i can't have him outside all the
time
but the cat yeah he will make an
appearance
sometime today he's very
very playful right now but okay
let's switch the topic from cat to to
polyp slash chronic
um so i really enjoyed this game because
as you see the title
i was a little shocked by the
um what happened to the queen in this
game and that's one of the reasons i
really wanted
to show this game just because it was
such an interesting
um idea that they had and i really wish
that
i was the one who if like if i was in
that position
i would go ahead and play like that
but i haven't really had much of a
queen sacrificing chance recently but
okay
so well so far so good normal opening
nobody is really doing
anything so um out of the ordinary
uh i believe for those of you who are
not very familiar with this opening
um white's idea is generally
to try and eventually get an e4
in some way ideally could be with e3
bishop d3
could be not could be just the whole
idea with e4 could be
ignored but e4 is one of the big ideas
that white tries to achieve
um some of the other things that white
could potentially try is with
bishop f4 bishop g5 both of those are
also
super interesting bishop black's bishop
definitely belongs
on d6 in the long run
um this bishop can be a little annoying
to just
make sense of because it really depends
if black
could actually get to a position that
could play something
like very feisty yeah potentially that
would be super cool but that doesn't
really seem realistic
yeah i think um something with b5
eventually is interesting to try and
just
you know kick around a little but
yeah um i think those are the like
main things to mention in this in this
type of con structures
because there are some who prefer to
continue with gc g3 bishop g2
but mainly g3 would uh you would play
from a different
uh different move order but
okay so enough about just uh talking
about where the pieces belong and let's
actually get to it
so after bishop g5 again there are many
different ways that
why black could continue but
in this game kramnik went for h6 and
he took on c4 so my first question for
you guys does anybody actually play this
with white or black
and if you do um well
maybe you can try to guide us on where
the pieces belong
if you don't play this feel free to type
in the chat and
um tell us well why to move
what do you want to do
oh well that's interesting you play this
with white and black wow
all right it's great a lot of player
actually do play this with white
or slash and y yeah okay i think that's
an interesting thing yeah
so william i think you're correct on uh
suggestion
of e4 i think e4 is something that i
think uh
when dc force happened the biggest thing
to think about is e4 because
if there was no e4 um then like the
dtake c4s could potentially become too
strong
so i agree d4 is definitely our move
now black has two different ideas that
could potentially transpose to each
other one of them is with bishop b4
so the idea would be to like play g5 and
take knight takes e4 when there's to
play
g5 and b5 but the the moves are
kind of similar because black's idea is
to go after this pawn
and i feel like um this bishop
should be on b4 after taking on c4
ideally black wants to keep his pawn
right
so these are just just thinking about it
super logically for someone who doesn't
even know much of theory in this
position i think these are
some of the main things to consider um
so
yeah anyways um so
in this position crown
went for g5 okay which is g3 normal
and he played b5 so what do you guys
think about this position
do you like it do you not like it do you
want to be white do you want to be black
and please try to tell me a move
suggestion for what should white
do
oh a4 i like that very very aggressive
um what i would suggest is be careful
because black does want to play b4 and
take on
your e4 so that's something to keep in
mind
do like it on i do like it for whites
too exactly
wow um yourself yeah i believe
um bishop e2 is very interesting
i do think that is actually the best
loop as well
um you could think about a3
if you are super worried about b4 i
don't think there is anything
absolutely wrong with a3 but at the same
time you would be kind of wasting some
time
um so
yeah i do think bishop e2 is the most
interesting one ah this is funny
so um here black plays bishop b7
and okay why to move what do you think
we should do there are other moves for
black we
we are going to take a quick look at b4
as well
but first of all bishop b7 what are you
gonna do ha this is funny
uh for for a little while tracy has been
uh mentioning that i should be streaming
alicia's and i am streaming alicia's
i i guess it's not showing i thought it
was clear that it's not leeches but yes
tracy i am only chess
with my personal account if that's
your what you're asking
sorry i can't i can't read the chat and
type at the same time so
i just answer out loud here
oh whoa i see h4 huh
wow so i believe h4 is actually quite
interesting
um h4 g4
95 oh this is looking real sharp now
this bishop g7 or 97
i believe those are
the ways
i don't really like bishop g7 though
bishop g7 like it doesn't make any sense
i could simply pick up on here
okay yeah i do think that h4 is
interesting
um but let's take a quick look because i
do want to mention this before before
we move along
so we're going to come back to h4 but i
want to solve this b4 question first
so if b4 we're definitely gonna go
knight a4
and if knight takes e4 uh i believe just
bishop
e5 is interesting i don't
i don't think f6 is a good idea because
well first of all
this knight is a serious problem
if you take take this is falling
g6 is happening bishop c4 is coming i
don't think this is i don't think
anybody wants to have this position
so oh so you had you knew the theory all
right
interesting good it's good to know about
the first 10
ish moves on most of the big openings
justin just to know where you're trying
to place your pieces
yep that is pretty horrible i agree i do
not think that taking
and playing f6 is a good idea
uh i guess white black could just try to
put the knights back
and then we could um
i kind of want to see if i can try and
well this part is mine i don't really
need to rush into eating it
i could just baby castle
i i think this is an interesting choice
of continuing this position
but yeah
um yeah
all right so let's just i think that's
what i wanted to mention just to
consider this bishop e5s if the knight
takes on e4
to just be aware of that all right
um oh boy
i changed the temperature on my air
conditioner and it's
accidentally giving it some really hot
air yeah kind of
making a sauna over here um
all right so in the game however after
bishop v2
bishop b7 was played by kramnik and i
think now this is an interesting choice
because we mentioned something with h4
and h4 is i think a really interesting
continuation
because after g4 knight e5
we also do have the knight f7 ideas
depending on what black does but just
the existence of it is pretty awesome
so if black was actually to play bishop
g7
we could take over here on f7
and play e5 and just want to like
somehow bring up the knights which is
kind of cool
um i don't think i would actually
um play this in a game and i guess
that's why chipotle is so stronger than
me
um but i do think that this is a this is
something just to keep in the back of
your mind that these kind of
tactics do exist
so okay uh that is another
also the jeep on yeah i agree the g1 is
also pretty pretty um
looking pretty good so i mean i guess if
you were to play something like knight
d7 i could consider taking a g4
i'm still hoping for some knight f7 e5s
but okay so that's another thing to keep
in mind when
in this type of position especially when
the center
is so weak this ideas with knight f7s
e5s having the other knight coming to e4
those are some ideas to keep in mind
again
it really depends on the position but
okay
so however in the game topolov played
short castle
and to be honest short castle was a
little weird to me because
i was under under the impression that we
wanted to
uh play from like to both sides of like
a
and h and then bring it to the center
but um this is actually another
interesting choice to go after at the
center
but was just it just feels like such a
chill move you just cast a little super
chill
yeah just wait to see what the opponent
does i think this was a very interesting
choice
for from white so
one thing um that we could consider
is well what if now
black played something like b4 do we
care about that
what do you think we should do after b4
and for the
la for my for my own
ability to not melt
up here i i i need to lower the
temperature
so i will be back in literally about 10
seconds
i apologize for the inconvenience but it
is
so hot in here it's just getting
soda
well thank you for staying with me
during this
10 seconds while i struggle to work the
the
freaking air condition i still i've been
living here for three years and i still
have issues with the air conditioning
well still pretty hot
um okay so
yeah i think b4 is an interesting thing
to look at
and i see some ideas with knight a4 i
think knight a4 is pretty awesome
um oh i see e5
i do think knight a4 is your second best
move
but i think e5 is just an easier way
because well first of all if he takes oh
oh boy oh boy
that is just gonna be a lovely
continuation this is just so fun to look
at
picking up b2 you don't really know you
can't really like you can't really put
the king anywhere safe you don't really
know what to do with the bishop
bishop c4 is popping up yeah this is
awesome
yeah i don't think kramnik would have
had any issues deciding that if he plays
b4 his game is going to be extremely
unpleasant
so in the game kramnik just went tonight
d7
we're playing 95. so probably played
knight e5
the idea behind it five was um
it's an idea that you already mentioned
i'm hoping that some of you guys will
consider it a little bit more deeply
before
we kind of give up the move so bishop g7
now what do you think we should do
so there are a bunch of different moves
that white
could do you could try for a4
you could try doing something with this
knight i guess anything besides
h4
yeah i do think coupons on f6 especially
when you're white
are pretty awesome so thank you thank
you emma i do
yep good choice yeah knight f7 pretty
awesome
uh keep in mind that if you wanted if
you didn't feel comfortable with
sacrificing you could always try
something with knight d7
if the queen takes you still have this
idea
right if the knight takes you have
bishop d6 and you stop castle so i think
this is another
interesting uh continuation if
you are not comfortable with sacrificing
your peace
for an unsee on that if
that you can't you know unseeable
future i don't think that is right
english
i know there's a foreseeable future so
uh good luck to my
english career but yes
um i do think that if you're
uncomfortable with sacrificing when you
can't see
too much ahead invisible future that is
much better thank you if you're
uncomfortable with the
invisible future of your sacrifice light
you don't have to do it i think it's an
awesome move
and it's it it was definitely a shock to
kramnik because nobody
wants to have that knight f7 right
so um
yeah i'd knight have seven i think yeah
also keep in mind that this game is
older so if you are planning on playing
this line with
the current theory make sure to double
check the current theory on this
so that is another thing to keep in mind
when you're watching somewhat
classic anything above like
seven eight years ago you should
definitely
check it i feel like you can still play
some of the
like seven eight years ago lines but you
still need to know what you're doing so
you need to be updated on the games
but yes ah nice this game invented night
episode yeah i mean
i wouldn't be shocked but yeah i think
this was a pretty awesome
thing to do um so you have to take it
you don't really have much of a choice
e5 you just gotta do it you could
actually think about
f4 but f4 is just not as good
um i think the problem with having this
f4
is that well after f4
there are b4s and the knight is you know
the ninth of
nope not that way the knight was
supposed to go to d6
and now you can't really you mean you
can't really get to that d6 anymore
so you could you should probably like
sacrifice another batch of knights
and you have to deal with hold that i i
wouldn't recommend this
why would you let your opponent slip
away so e5
keep everything tidy keep everything
clean
keep everything super uh
super duper annoying for your opponents
all right so knight d5 i don't think um
so what do you guys want to do now i
think the main two
the two main eye choices are either
knight e4
or something with like bishop h5 i think
those are the two
logical ways to continue
i'm not necessarily sure how much i
actually like bishops 5
i like that it stops any ideas with h5
but i don't think we should do that
because if the knight goes to e4
knight d6 is an actual threat but if we
play like bishop h5
king i guess g8 then knight e4 you're
not actually
threatening anything so i think we
should actually go for
um knight e4
yeah um yeah as i said if bishop h5
there could be just like in g8
maybe king j8 wasn't forced actually
well i don't want to go to f8
maybe e7 try and run away to that side
so i was
um i was watching the us junior girls
and there was this one game that really
captured my eye
uh i i believe jennifer you was black
either annie wang was white or chris i i
think it was annie wang
please feel free to correct me if i'm
wrong but
that game just the the way that game
went nah
that was probably krisa uh the game now
the way that game went it was so
tactical the king was running
it was probably karisa yeah because i
don't think any uh
any doesn't play e4 yeah so
um yeah so that was a that was an
interesting game
it was just so awesome so if you haven't
watched that
feel free to go check that out as well
it was just very mind blowing
crazy does have really awesome games
okay so that's another thing don't let
your opponent just slip away so bishop
is five you could be pushing the king
to go to the queen side so don't do that
just keep everything
super nice oh
um yeah i believe yeah i think i
completely agree with knight e4 96 being
accurate and then the queen
turned the game yeah i think that's the
most logical way to go about it
so king e7 as we said black king
gotta run because if that king doesn't
run then well that king is gonna get
toasted so the king has to run the king
has to stay
somewhere close to center ready to go to
the queen side
but even queen side won't necessarily be
safe
so i think that is something to consider
deeply and okay
so why to move what do you want to do
so i don't think black is actually
losing
i do think whites uh if white plays
every single move
super accurately then yes black is going
to be in trouble
um because white has
enough compensation for the sacrifice
knight but i wouldn't call this winning
or losing
the game still goes on for quite some
time
so i see some f4 and h4 ideas
but let me ask you why did we bring
knight to e4
exactly knight d6 thank you thank you
let's just continue with my d6
and um well
if you let me i will definitely eat your
piece
so
[Music]
that is a good description of having
your foot in the opponent's face
i would think i have my knight in upon
his face but
yeah i like that yeah i think after
knight
d6 the interesting thing is that well
blackish really does have to to do
something about this poor bishop
but this bishop is more like a lot more
like a tawn
tall pawn you can't really do anything
about it
i guess you could try to open it up but
this is also going to be way too
wasteful so
yeah so queen b6 seems to be
uh the best way to go about it we could
consider bishop g4 but i wanted to
mention i kind of wanted to emphasize a
little on what do we think about zork b8
so what do you think about the strict v8
to be completely honest i
don't feel that difference between rich
b8 or
queen b6 i just feel like
both of them are equally
unfortunate but what move would you want
to do i don't think r8 is doing much for
black's position
but at the same time having the queen a
little closer to the king
feels a little um more comfortable so
you could consider f4 we could consider
bishop h5
simply going knight f7
i think those two are the best ones yeah
sure let's take a look at f4
[Music]
well first of all takes i don't exactly
think that is going to have
much to it because now rook f7 that will
be such a pretty mate
um so that is one way that we could go
about this i really gotta get this queen
somewhere though
maybe i could just attack the bishop for
it first
i'm just trying to get the queen to come
out
yeah i'm pretty comfortable with this
position to be honest
yeah i think this is a good position you
just get your pieces out
and this king in the middle you can't
really do much about it i guess you
could try to take over here
i just need to move this bishop
somewhere bishop f3
i like this position four whites i mean
i would prefer it if i got some mate out
of it but i don't
think realistically this position has
that much to offer
it's just really great uh spatial
advantage
and it's nothing there's nothing wrong
with converting your advantage to
like from having more space to um
having more material or just i think
the whole idea with converting advantage
is very
underrated so yeah
okay so good yeah i'm glad it mentioned
this f4 and if he doesn't
if black doesn't take it black could
potentially try something with queen b6
the idea is because this pawn is going
to be pinned
something could happen to e5 so you
can't just keep pushing because
there is knight takes e5 right
um so you could just play the kingish
one and um
i think that's interesting but knight e3
is
uh it could get a little tricky so if
you are planning on playing f4
i would say to just um keep in mind
just be aware of the dangers and i guess
that's why
f4 isn't exactly the favorite uh instead
against rp8 the favorite is actually
just getting the bishop out
or bishop g4 one of these two and then
trying to play f4 i believe one of the
ideas is that you just want to get the
queen out you just need that queen to
get out
so um yeah that is that is just one
other thing
yeah i agree f4 doesn't necessarily feel
the best either okay i'm glad there's
such good understandings
among chats all right so i i feel like
we are getting a better grip on the
position
so what about queen b6 shall we still
try to do something with our bishop
do you want to just play f4 and just
yeah i wouldn't recommend that just yet
also wow it got really cold again
i really don't like this this
temperature in its room
no wonder i'm always wearing hoodies and
i never get a good feeling of actually
what's the temperature
all right i see some uh there are a lot
of preference for bishop h5
i like that what about bishop g4
i see somebody saying bishop g4
i mean if i could have that bishop i
mean
i think one of the the problems is
how am i going to get my other pieces
out
not just a bishop so i like bishop g4
more because the problem is with bishop
g4 even if you have
zero intentions of sacrificing now black
has to be like oh my god
take that and it's kind of like just
whoops
it's kind of just tricky you don't
necessarily want to
um get this get this pawn
right away you gotta get some queen in
too but
at the same time i feel like it's just
tricky because your opponent
is just gonna be scared of it and you
should play moves like that you should
play moves that make your opponent
um be a little scared
even if you have no intentions of
following up with that plan
so ah the sugar street queen g4 i like
that too
i kind of like just queen c2 queen g6
i think that's a little bit more
straightforward
yeah okay i think you guys have the
right ideas yes
good good awesome so in the game
uh kramnik played rook f8
and i believe the idea was um quite
understandable well i'm i'm i'm gonna
run with my king man
i'm gonna run i'm gonna run i feel like
that's
that's the general idea to just get the
king running
um i do not think we should even
consider this
because take and we just don't have
enough pieces we just have one strong
night over there so i would not
recommend this
uh don't i don't think you should go
after um
after ghost tactics
but i do think that you should bring in
more pieces so queen c2 you want to
bring in queen to g6
um you want to just go after this
awesome e6 i don't know why this is
giving me so much
um just it's reminding me so much of the
game that i told you
um that the cresa jennifer game
a lot of it is a lot of the ideas that
i'm seeing here
was also in that game so i think that
was that's a nice connection
i don't know if you guys saw that game
if you haven't you gotta see that game
that
that game was really awesome squishy
girl plays really well
and i'm gonna play her in the u.s
championships next week so
yay um
okay
okay so yes queen c2 um
now how do you guys think black could
try to
defend
what do you think black should try to do
this is actually a pretty hard way for
this is like a very
interesting but quite hard move for
black to play and heads up kramnik did
not find this move
hello kitty
oh i see some king moves some nightmares
some candles oh hello
well it's your new instructor mr peachy
they're actually
okay kitty you gotta come down
so oh i see a rook g8 i don't know if
this move was calculated
or if it was just somewhat of a uh
shooting but rook sheet is pretty strong
good job
you're give eight and you drink f7 and
you didn't
work five and you didn't really do much
of a calculation you just
i mean i agree queen g6 is pretty scary
and i
honestly don't really understand why
kramnik just took on d4 so in this in
the game kramnik just played queen takes
d4
and i think that was an interesting
choice but at the same time
i don't know if i would do that
just feels so just
i don't i don't wanna i don't want this
queen g6 like i would do anything i can
to stop this queen g6
so that ktg idea i mean kid is sitting
right here right now at least not
attempting to teach um
so i think uh one other one not one
some of the other moves that black could
try to do and defend the position
was well i see a lot of h5 so let me
address this h5 the problem with h5 is
i will still play queen g6 and it
doesn't matter if you take over here
because i have queen g5
and something with bishop f6 i can still
take it
and well your king is pretty um
pretty honored right now okay
he wants a head drop oh my god i will
not be able to play us championships
imagine i'm like in a time trouble like
i got two minutes
and he his majesty wants a face drop or
a headroom
oh my god come on kitty
yeah online chess plus cats
it's actually funny the first round i'm
playing sabrina
um sabina and we both have cats
so that will be a war of cats i guess
whose cat will meow louder
but okay so
the name of my cat is actually cat just
a different language i call it peachy
which literally means cat so
i wasn't very creative with that but you
can also think about it in a poetic way
that he's the only cat in the whole
world for me
i wasn't thinking about that when i
named him but sure we can make it a
little philosophical
all right um so yes i do not think h1
works
but to be completely honest if not queen
g6 with idea queen g5
then h5 would be a good defense so if
white doesn't see his queen g6 but i
don't i queen c2's idea is to play queen
g6 so i don't think
uh white would necessarily miss this
idea so
um anyways the other the best way to
defend this position
actually is rook g8 i have no idea
um just how
one would think about this i think the
best way to think about it
is if you have already trained yourself
to
not want to have the dropping pieces
so this one is a dropping piece right
so we don't really want to draw i mean
it's a defenseless piece
so we don't want the pieces to be
defenseless so we could we could play
g8 with that logic um
and then if you play queen g6 black
could try to play knight c7
oh holy guacamole and
i i mean black is just defending but
it's just
so what is the right word for this
position
this is just a sad position it's so
horrible to try and defend this
um eric i am not a junior anymore
i i still feel 18 but i am 22 so i
did not play in the juniors i will play
in the u.s women's championship next
week
and i really have to finish my
preparation for that
so don't tell it to my opponent when
you're talking to my opponents
go on their streams i'm super prepared
oh my god i got the top 10 world players
preparing for me go with that
spread some fear no i i
i i haven't been preparing that deep
but don't tell that to anybody
um yeah anyways
so besides my uh awesome us
championships preparation
let's um let's go back to
the game at hand
yeah ah yeah i know well i guess
thank you for your honesty eric no i'm
just hoping to play
good quality games i just want to play
good quality games
because um it's it's really
i don't know the one of the best life
lessons i got from
um the eric rosen was that
he's so honest about his goals he
doesn't try to
make it look super big and he's not he's
not like oh my god i want to be world
champion one day which a lot of players
do actually say
and when somebody asks me um
ask me like what are your chess goals
like what do you want to do for this
tournament
i feel like i'm kind of obligated to say
oh i want to win it but that is not
necessarily true sometimes like
you it's you want to just play good
chess if you win it's
awesome i'm not going to object to that
but yeah
um i'm i'm considering that uh depending
on
how well the the games go i so how high
is
how high student am i so i it's a little
weird because with uscf
i'm not i'm i'm uh the bottom half
but when you uh close to the end
with the uscf but with feeder rating i'm
actually kind of close to the
middle so i think that's actually a
little interesting
so it depends how you look at it but
yeah
so yeah big shout out to eric rosen
for indirectly teaching me that lesson
it was a very interesting
just i feel like it's just sudden it's
just like you should be honest with
yourself your goals and
i feel like if you're someone that they
just see once a year then you can just
like yeah i want to win all tournaments
but if you're more of a familiar face i
don't feel like i don't feel obligated
to say i want to win this tournament
and then i want to qualify for the men
championship but i want to win that i'm
not going to say something like that
as funny as it sounds okay
um so
after knight c7
what do you think we should do as white
this is a pretty tricky position
and i don't i didn't find the best move
here
the best move is queen e4 which is a
little
to be honest it is quite weird so if you
are not finding these moves
please don't feel free to um
don't feel free to um you know
feel weird just just it's just a hard
move to find
and okay uh with that note i'm gonna
leave it at f4
is to come and um i'm gonna leave it at
that
so let's go back to the position at hand
where kramnik slightly messed it up with
queen takes d4
um after queen takes d4 i think
now we could start with let's go to
queen g6 right
main threat i want to eat over here and
then over there
so you have to stop that um so
what do you guys think what do you think
happens if queen takes g4
do you think queen takes g4 is the best
move or do we have anything else
uh do i want to earn the gm title um
that is a good question i think
in a long run yes but that is not in my
in my close future
goal because i i am preparing for the
mcat
how is it going can anybody hear me
i think the i don't know my mic somehow
died literally i wasn't touching it i
wasn't even looking at it
i guess the sound is back but i don't
expect it to be so great
so no i wish my cat was that trained
that would be so useful during online
exams but no
um he he's not okay
um let's just go back to the game i was
mentioning after queen g6 and i
i brought up a question on well where do
you guys where where do we want
to um well how can black stop this
and i don't think black can ha
oh my god i gave my answer to gm
question all right i'll give it i'll
give you the i'll repeat the answer
a little deeper in the game because we
still haven't gotten to the cool parts
and i really want to continue to the
cool parts
so i feel like um queen g4 is the
humane move um black could potentially
try something with bishop f6 but i
i doubt humans would do this
especially because well knight b7 is
coming taking over here is coming so i
could just take
i could just take which one should i
take if i take over here
queen takes f6 but then can't i just
pick that up
like queen e4 this is falling
i don't know this just feels pretty
awesome
um so queen g6 queen takes g4
of course we're gonna take that and uh
knight b7 super logical move as well
so now this was a very interesting
position too
so i am going to uh ask you guys this
question
white to move what do you want to do uh
heads up
if you want to play knight d6 there's
nothing wrong with that but if you want
to play knight d6
please tell me what would you do after
that so knight d6 king's gotta go to d8
then what do you do so
i'll give you guys about 30 seconds or
so
wow well don't even need 30 seconds
no that is actually very interesting
choice yeah
good job a4 is the best move because the
thing is even
after a4 you take on b7 i'm just gonna
take on d7 and this is a super lost
position for black
just this is coming uh the strict the
stroke is opening
um however
after um after a4
b4 seems to be the strongest way to go
about this
so now again why to move how do you
think we
can try and open up this position a
little bit
so now while you guys are telling me
what should twice do
i'm gonna answer the gm question so um i
feel like i
do want to deep down but i don't think
that that's something that i will be
able to actually dedicate my life to
because achieving
g the gm file and the rating needed it's
gonna be so
it's gonna take a few years uh but i
don't have those few years now because
i'm um i'm finishing my undergrad and
uh this especially this this this
semester next few months i'm preparing
for mcat
to enter the medical school and then
after medical school
it's the whole um well medical school
and then residency
and then so i feel like i have chosen a
different life path
but i do think that um well if you
consider
doctor i could become a gm in medical
field
so um i no i don't think um
i think that's something that maybe
potentially in like future
i would consider deeply but not in the
next few years
which university am i uh saint louis
university
and all right i see some ideas that
bring in the roof bringing the knight
i don't think we should touch this side
that light is just awesome
you take it ha i will eat on d7 and that
should be enough to make you cry
so how about just roxy one because just
thinking about it logically this rook
here is not really doing anything
hello but rook on c1 you're trying to
open up
so after rook c1 what do you want to do
after
c3 your
instructor mr pishi
yeah what profession do i want to do
surgery
definitely yeah
yep we gotta take this you gotta try and
open this up
so we take c3 i believe b3 is the
strongest way to go because well if
even if you try to take this with the
knights again
there are so many different ways or why
to win
i think the the coolest way is just with
queen
uh e7 you just want to pick pawns up
so yeah i think that would that would be
uh uh that would be a cool
idea
yeah so anyways um
yeah my c3 doesn't feel good b3 and even
on the other hand v3 is pretty awesome
after b3 we can simply go for c4
this is where the game got really
interesting so
black plays rook g8 check we gotta save
the the knight we don't want to lose our
knight
and in this position white made a
slight inaccuracy and
white just took on d5 which
is the title of wait where is my queen
as you can see
because he just kind of gave his queen
up but
um the best way was not to sacrifice the
queen surprise surprise
the best way was to play h3 now
i don't know if um i would like to
interview to paulov on this
so paul if you see this stream
i would like your answer on why
you played h3 and why didn't play
history
but that sounds quite unlikely to happen
so we're just going to look at h3 by
ourselves
i think h3 the the cool thing is that
well if you took over here
uh after taking on g4 the
this knights then the rook are both
hanging so
that makes perfect sense like an easy
end game win
however i think not taking was the
concern something potentially with
queenie two but then we have like queen
takes e6 and
because the queen on g4 is not um
is not defending e6 anymore so you pick
that up
and this is actually much much better
you
you move the queen next move and this
bishop is opening up so i think that was
a
more interesting choice
but come on who can say no to giving up
a queen like that
right so all right so
what do you guys think this position
why to move what do you think white
should do
also do you think white is winning or do
you think black can survive this
i like white too yeah i think it's a
little weird position to look at
just because um when you're attacking
you don't exactly expect
to sacrifice the queen and not get made
next few moves so i think that's an
interesting way to look at it
um so yeah rookie eight
now i see most people are saying some
somewhere between rp1 and knight d6
all right thank you 9d6 i'm not saying
rugby one is not good but knight beast
knight d6
just it's more annoying because the poor
guy just played rookie 8 and we're going
after it
so now uh this was actually a very
awesome um skill game that
topolov did just he put rook c4
i feel like rook c4 is just so
trying to find the right word but i
can't it's just
so it's just so destroying like
you have to move your queen and look how
beautifully
everything is defended and you can just
simply pick up that pawn
and it's just so beautiful exactly it's
so classy
um after take knight b6 or before
everything is just so chill and your
pawns
this pawn is something that actually
initially um
made me think that would think just hey
is this a potential um
issue but i think this is actually
just eye candy which i can eat
anytime soon um e8 is coming up
and okay i think this was
a very interesting game we still have a
few moves to go so i want to ask
why to move what do you think we should
do oh you're a medical student last year
in portugal wow
nice yeah i'm i'm still
trying to um studying for mcat is
painful it's just i
keep like my wicks are flying by don't
they
please tell me my sound is here no it
says that my audio input is here
well the sound is moving
um yeah please let me know if you're
having trouble hearing me
um oh no youtube is still showing
never mind never mind okay uh there was
a mention about
uh i mean boston he is a doctor
yeah i was very impressed by him when i
was just
um where i was just beginning my chest
career
yeah but i think he got his gm title
before he got
became a doctor so i think that's a
little easier i have my
woman grandmaster and my international
master titles
but i don't i feel like it's a little
bit different level comparing
me to boston how long
how long do i finish my studies oh man
it's continuous
yeah two years undergrad i've got left
and
the four years med school once a year
residency
i would say seven so never ends yeah so
i see there's a lot of different ideas
with knight b5 and so
but you have to take the i feel like
this was a particularly interesting posi
like right now because like even though
the there is a material imbalance
topalive took the time and he played h3
like actually when i saw this move um
earlier when i was just
trying to prepare a game for you guys i
actually laughed so hard i was like
i had to i was drinking tea i had to
clean around
um so yeah this h3 was just such a
funny move to me like you don't expect
to see h3 happening in this type of
position
so yeah uh cramming continued with h5
chill knight of seven chill e6
and it's not so chill because if you
take it well i'm not it's not going to
be too chill for black right
so yeah um
[Music]
yeah i think this h3 was such a fun
thing
and um just it's just painful for black
because black can't really do anything
black has this
um black has this like extra queen well
not extra because the white has enough
material
for it more than enough but it's like
when you see a queen on the board you
don't expect to see
these kind of positions you expect to
see more interesting
more trying to attack so i think that
was a
particularly um painful game for kramnik
um yeah i have enough painful games i
look i know a painful game when i see
one
anyways uh let me just try to finish
this up we're on the last moves
so basically the
kramnik resigned here because well i
also knight c7 and rook b7 are coming up
and i think this was particularly lovely
because
in the last like i want to say five
seven moves white wasn't actually trying
to blackmaid
white was just advancing his position
and i think that's one of the
big concepts that we um
we uh tend to forget about when we're
attacking
we don't i feel like we don't take a
moment to just take a breath
and then realize and then reevaluate
just figure out what the position needs
when we see the king we just want to go
after the king so i think
um i think that's the little
psychological lesson that i wanted to
share
and yeah i guess that is the game i
wanted to show you for today
and i see a lot of interesting questions
and comments in the chat
but i do not um i don't want to keep
pepe waiting so i am gonna go ahead and
say goodbye to you guys
i will see you again on friday on twitch
but me until then
have fun with pepe have a great rest of
your night